Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Richard Lops, and
today I'm joined by a return guest, Dr. Christopher
Kavanaugh and also a new guest, Dr. Matthew Brown.
They are the hosts of Decoding the Gurus podcast.
Dr. Kavanagh is associate professor in the College of
Contemporary Psychology at Rikkyo University, and Dr. Brown is
professor of psychology at Central Queensland University. And today
we're going to talk about decoding the gurus. So
welcome back, Dr. Kavanaugh. Welcome to the show, Dr.
Brown. It's a great pleasure to everyone.
Hello. Good morning.
We've talked. We, we started off with overtalking. That's
a terrible way to start.
Yeah, it's already what the, it's already the evening
there in Japan and Australia or what?
That's right, yeah, the late afternoon, but I'm considerate
and just think about other people's time zones, so
that's, that don't worry. Yeah, that's, that's, that's it.
But not, it's, it's early for you, but it's
very convenient for me and Matt. So that's why,
good morning to you.
Yeah. So, I, I mean, I would like to
to start by asking you, what got you guys
interested in gurus? I mean, why are you so
interested in this topic and why and how did
you start your podcast?
Go ahead, Chris.
Uh, WELL, so I think in my case, being
interested in the, um, the kinds of figures we
cover related to pre-existing interest in, um, like conspiracy
theorists and anti-vax communities and this kind of, um,
new religious movements and so on, and Um, the
secular gurus that we discussed, figures like Jordan Peterson
or the Weinstein brothers, uh, and such, um, were
not directly the same as those kind of figures,
but there were interesting parallels, um, and they were
kind of getting A lot of uh attention in
media and online, in online spaces and intellectual um
pundit sort of spaces, so it was kind of
uh A new phenomenon are connected to pre-existing interest
in Um, related topics, conspiracy, communities, and, and so
on, so there were some interesting parallels and some
things that were, that were different, and that's why
it, it kind of grabbed my interest, and then
there was also the fact that um I listened
to podcasts and what would be called like heterodox
or alternative media for a long time, um, and
noticed that, Uh, a lot of the people active
there were displaying these, these characteristics, so it was
kind of like, um, something of digital ethnography, but
not imagined as that, that, you know, listening to
people like Joe Rogan and so on talk, um,
and then noticing the audience dynamics and the different
features that they were doing, and then I ended
up, um, Talking and commenting about it online, on,
on Twitter, um, and before that on, on forums
and such, and Matt was somebody else doing that
at the time and with a similar academic bent
to him, so we ended up, uh, talking together
online, and then started to write a paper, which
we have not yet finished, but it is still.
It's, it's, it's getting closer, it's inching ever closer,
uh, about this, this phenomenon of secular gurus, um,
and in the discussions for that paper, I suggested,
um, that I had been thinking of doing a
podcast, um, around these figures, and Matt was interested
and capable of co-hosting and. And the rest is
history.
Uh, uh, BUT I, I mean when you say
that, uh, it aligns with your interests, uh, does
it align with your res with you guys' research
interests, I mean, in terms of what you do
academically, anthropologically and psychologically, or is it more personal
interests?
Well it's a bit of both, but it does
align with our research interests. Um, Chris's background is
in the, the, the study of religion and how
rituals and things like that are expressed in society
and um. Uh, um, YOU know, I've got a
background in studying anti-vax and complementary and alternative therapies
and just general belief formation generally. So both of
us in different ways have sort of just got
this general interest in why people believe the things
that they do. I mean, usually the things they
believe are stupid. And it's interesting where I'm being
somewhat tongue in cheek. Um, BUT, um, but you
know, it's, it's interesting to, to know why, and
a big part of why is, is they get
these beliefs, um, from trusted figures. So it sort
of begs the question. Um, WHO is good at
making people trust them to get themselves perceived as
an, an authority, um, that it, um, and, you
know, likewise, how do these characters, I guess, decrease
trust in other sources of knowledge, generally institutions and
conventional sources. So, so, uh, yeah, um, as well
as that we're both sort of tragic participants in
the online discourse and, You know, just, um, routinely
get provoked by various figures, so, yeah, so it
all came together.
I would also say, uh, Ricardo, I was involved
in like skeptical circles like UK skepticism, uh, in,
in the past, so you know, that, that movement
was kind of focused around promoting, Science and, and
like in early stages, you know, around um science
debates uh against creationism and evolution and that kind
of thing, but the interesting aspect for me was
that, Um, a lot of the figures who were
coming up in, in the kind of nascent guru
space, they often, to me, seemed to drape themselves
in the cloak of like science and skepticism and
critical thinking and being heterodox thinkers. So, it, it
was kind of like that they are claiming the
mantle of, of skepticism and, and critical thought, and
then deploying it very, Uh, badly, at, at the
very least, or in a, you know, in service
of often quite strong ideology. So, that was part
of the, the thing that motivated interest for me
is like, people claiming that they were doing, like,
skeptical, critical thinking, but to me it looked very
Similar to what I'd seen with conspiratorial thinking, and
I'll just er er round off Matt's sharp edge
by saying that like, when he's referred to what
people mainly believe is stupid, I think he is
taking for granted that people would understand. He's referring
to things like extremely strong anti-vaccine views or like
anti-establishment views that everybody in establishments is lying to
all the time, UFOs are, you know, real and
haven't been disclosed, and that there's, uh, like new
physics that has been prohibited. So, when you're familiar
with all of those kind of narratives that people,
Push, they can seem like, you know, very silly,
but they're often um not on the face of
it, like completely ridiculous, right? So I'm just, just
saying Matt, you maybe you want to put it
another way,
let, let me round off Chris's rounding off uh
of, of my statement. I mean, basically, uh, in,
in psychology where we are, we are. Just generally
interested in, in attitude formation, motivations, all that stuff.
And the, I guess the null hypothesis, the basic
premise is that we're perfectly rational beings and we
perceive the world perfectly accurately, and psychologists are particularly
interested in the ways in which we depart from
that. So for instance, just today, I played a
game called Pickleball for the first time, which is
like tennis for old people. Um, AND, um, and
despite it being, uh, not a particularly adventurous sport,
I severely overestimated my abilities and dived around after
the ball, fell over a few times, and now
I'm in a great deal of pain. So, so
that's an example of just, uh, overestimating one's own
talents, right? A, a, a kind of form of
narcissism, which is a almost ubiquitous, um, psychological trait.
So, so when I Uh, jokingly refer to things
that people believe are usually stupid. Uh, I include
myself in that because an awful lot of our
beliefs, uh, are not perfectly rational and not perfectly.
Good, good, good.
No, you know, it's very interesting because you mentioned
the skeptical community, and I mean, it's not that
I was ever directly involved. In any skeptical community,
I mean, I was sort of a sympathizer of
that for a few years, but it's interesting because
there are some people, of course not all of
them, but there are some people that were part
or are still part of those kinds of communities.
I mean skeptical community, rational community. You can have
perhaps even new atheists. To that and so on
where they seem to have, even though they might
deny it, they seem to have some guru-ish kinds
of thoughts and behaviors. I mean, like for example,
new atheists and we could even talk here about
people like, uh, I mean just to mention some
of the most prominent ones, Richard Dawkins and Sam
Harris. Uh, I mean, the, the, for example, the
kind of claims that they make about religion, many
of them seem to run counter to the science
of religion, to what, for example, cognitive. SCIENTISTS, anthropologists
say, uh, about religion, uh, and, and so I
mean they, they, they seem to be sometimes very
arrogant in the way that they talk about um.
What they consider to be irrational behaviors, the behaviors,
some behaviors from religious people, for example, and others,
and uh I mean when it comes to the
skeptical community, for example, I, I, er, I've always
seen, not again, not in er every, not everyone
had that kind of attitude, but I've always seen
that sort of, that sort of. TENDENCY to, OK,
so for example, if I just memorize all the
different logical fallacies out there and if I just
memorize all of the different cognitive biases and heuristics
identified by cognitive scientists, then I mean I'm immune
to irrational. Basically, so I mean, you know, I
don't know if you've also noticed those kinds of
attitudes and behaviors among people who are part of
those communities, but it seems that many times people
tend to think that, oh OK, no, no, I,
I, I don't have those kinds of irrational behaviors,
but actually they do. So
yeah, so I mean definitely. The rationalist and skeptical
communities have their fair share of non-rational dogmatists and,
and people invoking Bayesianism and, and little Bayesian um
equations to justify, Their arguments, right, just inserting if
it let X be that I'm right, right? And,
and so on. But, uh, and I think that
Richard Dawkins and Sam Harris suffer from no shortage
of confidence in their opinions on, on various issues.
Um, AND I would agree that especially in the
case of Sam Harris. He doesn't seem to have
almost any interest in the research literature, uh, around
like, uh, the psychology of extremism, or whatever, because
he had a couple of bad interactions with, uh,
particular academics, I think anthropologists in general, and so
he's written off the entire field. Um, PERHAPS not
the most rational response, but, um, I will, Um,
in defense of them, a little bit, say that
I, I think in part that especially with Dawkins,
that Yeah, it's better to think of them less
of a researcher, when, I mean, Richard Dawkins, you
know, a, an important figure in the history of
like promoting, um, understanding,
uh, evolutionary biology,
right, yes, yes, and, and the, you know, the
selfish gene and so on. Matt and I, big
fans of that, that book, and, and actually his
evolutionary writing in, in general, is still pretty good,
I think, but the um, When it comes to
religion and stuff like that, I see both him
and Sam Harris, Sam Harris being, uh, in a
slightly different category, uh, but, but Richard Dawkins as
being like kind of an atheist activist in a
way, and so when he's writing about religion, he's
mostly talking about like a, a fundamentalist, um, you
know, creationist or, or fundamentalist, uh, creationist position in,
Mostly monotheistic Abrahamic traditions, right, and I, I think
in that context, his arguments are often, you know,
against that, reasonable, but when you are talking more
about the like social or Cultural evolutionary role of
religious traditions and societies. He doesn't seem to have
very, very much of note to say. And as
he's gotten older, I think his opinions have become
stronger and more like publicly stated and perhaps less
well informed, so. Yeah, I, I, I kind of
concur with your assessment and, and definitely with the,
um, the rationalist community in our experience, we've, we've
looked at a couple of figures from that movement,
and there, there is variation there, you know, there
are people within there that, that are practicing like
good approaches to things, but there's, there's a lot
of, um, People dressing up their intuitions in, in
scientific and, and Bayesian logic or, or that kind
of thing and, um, yeah, so you, I think
the advice with, with any of these things is
like, you know, read whatever blogs you want, consume
whatever content you want, but just do it critically,
um, and yeah, and be wary when people tell
you they're like the most rational, um person approaching
things because usually not, usually not.
I mean, I guess that if someone tells you
directly, OK, so I'm a rational, I'm a very
rational person, I'm a great critical thinker, you should
take that with a huge grain of salt. I
mean, I, I was just thinking, for example, about
that guy that I was not even aware of
him at all. I just became aware of him
because he participated in a recent, I mean fairly
recent Piers Morgan episode where Slavoyzek was also there.
Warren Smith, and and and, and he was presented
as the foremost critical thinker or something like that.
And I and I, and I, and I was
like, what? What? I never, I never heard of
this guy. And then immediately, I mean, and one
thing that really bothered me immediately was that when
he was starting to discuss with Slavayzek. Brought up,
oh, OK, so communism killed 100 million people, and
I'm like, oh, OK, here we go again. The
figure from the Black Book of communism, yeah, communism
was not great, but come on, the Black Book
of communism is just BS because for people who
know, for people who are aware of this, I
mean they know that the main author, the I
mean the The other authors, apart from the main
author are distanced themselves from the book because they
said publicly that the main author from the very
beginning wanted to arrive at the 100 million figure
there, so I mean he was already working toward.
Uh, TOWARD creating artificially that 100 million figure because
it sounds like a very round number and so
I mean the way he ended up making that
number up, uh, he even considered like for example,
oh. People who were supposed to be born that
weren't born also come as deaths of communism. So
what are we talking about? And this is the
guy who is the foremost critical thinker who's Using,
I don't know, anti-communist propaganda. I mean, you can
be anti-communist, but it's just resorting to that sort
of propaganda. So immediately then and there I was
like, yeah, I'm not taking this guy seriously, so.
Yeah, and I, I, I don't think it's a,
it's a competition, is it? Um, IT, it, it
doesn't, it doesn't really matter if it was 50
million or 150 million, right, or, you know, it's,
it's, it's the, the argument isn't based on that
sort of thing. Um, YEAH, look, but getting back
to your other point, uh, certainly, look, there's these
big warning signs that some of the gurus we
cover and some people online. Will speak directly to
their own wonderfully high IQ, which is always very
funny. Great big red flag in somebody who's telling
you their IQ and, and telling you they're a
very high IQ person. But there's lots of other
ways to kind of signal that you are a
very smart person. Uh, YOU'VE probably seen all the
bios on people's things, and they call themselves a
free thinker or a first principles thinker, you know,
add that on to, to Bayesianism and, uh, uh,
and it's, you know, so these things often end
up being Basically intellectual virtue signaling, which, uh, you
know, just, you know, acting a role and uh
playing the role of a very wise, very erudite,
very well informed, very well educated, super smart person,
so, so trust me, believe me, um, and don't
listen to, you know, don't, don't try to deconstruct
my arguments or, or, or or look too carefully,
uh, because, uh, you know, so yeah, we, we,
um, we, we look for those sorts of signs.
Yeah, I, I also like those people who finish
PhDs and then everything that they do has to,
I mean, every place they put their name on,
they have to have PhD in the front, and
then it's like even if they're writing something. That
has nothing at all to do with their area
of expertise. Oh, blah blah blah, PhD. Oh, OK,
so now you have to listen to me because
I have a PhD in, uh, I don't know,
psychology and I, and I'm talking about quantum mechanics.
Exactly, yeah. So, um, so Chris, Chris could probably
tell you more, but, um, you know, that's, that's
another thing where people are, are straying well outside
of their lane. So, it's like you said, you
know, getting some expertise in a particular area takes,
takes a long time, and you can gain a
fair bit of expertise in something specific, and it
doesn't make you. Uh, A, a, a general purpose
expert on, on everything, and I think, um, the,
um, the, a certain degree of hubris, um, can,
can creep in, especially when you are a media
commentator and you attract a certain following, and you
have a lot of people out there who are
telling you that you are the, uh, the smartest
business person in the world, you can see that
it can be a little bit, uh, tempting. To
um stray into all kinds of areas and start
opinionating on them more confidently than you should, so
it's perfectly fine to have opinions, we've all got
opinions about everything, um but I think it's a,
it's a matter that about the degree to which
you claim, the, the mantle of specialist expertise and
how willing you are to discount the advice from
people who might know a lot about a particular
specialized topic than yourself.
Yeah, but I mean, tell us more about the
gurometer and the 10, I think it's 10 traits
that you came up with. I mean, how did
you come up with the gurometer and explain each
of those 10 traits which I think are Anti-establishment,
Cassandra complex conspiracy mongering, occultishness, galaxy brainness, grievance mongering,
profiteering, pseudo profound BS, revolutionary theories, and self-aggrandizement. I
mean, tell us about that.
Uh, YEAH, so basically, the The area that we're
talking about is um people that present themselves as
alternative epistemic authorities, if you like, charismatic epistemic authorities,
they're often providing like a, a world. And like
Matt mentioned, claiming polymorphic, um, abilities. So, it's a,
like guru as a, a broad category has existed
in a whole bunch of different cultures and there's
related concepts around, you know, like prophets and And
shamans and, and, and so on, but, um, we
are focused on the, uh, variation of that that
emerged in the more contemporary period and that draws
its authority from secular sources, so often this is
from academic knowledge or at least academic, uh, disciplines
like a, a knowledge, specialist knowledge of science, specialist
knowledge of history. Of psychology, these kind of things.
So they might um make reference to religious or
spiritual traditions, but they're often interpreting them for, you
know, Jungian psychology or something like that, right? Like,
so the, the reliance is not, uh, usually on
like divine insight. It's, it's kind of more grounded,
um, at least superficially in secular sources, and, um,
When we were looking at, at characters who fitted
around us, and, and a lot of it in
the beginning was people online attracting large followings, who,
who were seen as these kind of charismatic figures,
giving people, uh, you know, life, life advice and
uh opinionating on a bunch of topics. So, like
I mentioned, you know, um, Jordan Peterson fits the
mold quite, quite well. Um, AND once we had
covered, uh, a couple of them, and, and also
just in discussions, we noticed that there were like
recurrent features which kept coming up every episode because
the format of the podcast is that we would
take a long form piece of content, and we
could, we'd kind of like critically examine the tropes
that were in it. And, There were various tropes
that continued to reoccur, and this is what we
have tongue in cheek referred to as a gometer,
right? There's 11 characteristics because we added moral grandstanding
and, and you mentioned them, right, the things like
polymorphic self-presentation, anti-establishment, uh, Posturing and, and in that
sense, it's not just like you have some critiques
of some mainstream institution, but I can make, it's
more like everyone in every mainstream institution is lying
to you all the time. You can't trust academia,
you can't trust media, you can't trust politicians, right,
you can't trust me, the alternative epistemic authority, and
then, Um, thing, there are things that I think
are relatively straightforward, like extreme narcissism and self-aggrandizement, um,
the tendency towards conspiracy mongering, um, some of the
things that maybe people wouldn't immediately grasp is that
the figures tend to have, uh, or lay claim
to revolutionary theories that are not yet being recognized.
Maybe they're recognized by their followers. Uh, BY their
followers as very important, but not by the relative,
the relevant like expert communities, right? So it could
be in physics or it could be in biology
or whatever, and, and maybe they even have credentials
in those fields, but they have theories where they're
not just like attempting to contribute to a discipline.
They have theories that they believe will completely revolutionize,
uh, entire fields. And perhaps the world, right, if
they're properly understood, but often a very limited track
record of any actual, you know, output or research
or anything that you might normally associate with that.
So, the claim to revolutionary theories, um, is, is
somewhat distinctive. Moral grandstanding is often presenting their motivations
as like extremely pure. They're only motivated by. Um,
THE best things, and that if people are criticizing
them, they are morally suspect because they're standing against
their kind of righteous crusade or against like historic
evils, right, and, and related to that, when we
are talking about cultish dynamics, we're really talking about
the tendency for people to um manipulate their followers
and create these very, very strong parasocial attachment to
them. As figures, and um a, a kind of
binary worldview where following the person, consuming their content,
promoting them, makes you a good and thoughtful person.
And if you are part of the people that
are critical, or might be like reading critical material
about them, then you're part of, you know, the,
the evil cabal, which is set on destroying the
world and often attached to nefarious forces and all
this kind of thing. So all of these are
like features that don't typically go. With people that
are public intellectuals, right, sometimes the, the, the concepts
overlap, but in general, public intellectuals tend to like,
be more focused on a specific subject uh that
is related to their expertise, to include more caveats
around and limitations, when they're making claims, right, and
to not engage in this level, Of kind of
personalized audience, uh, manipulation might be one word for
it, but at least like cultivated attachment, right, you
know, even if you regard people like Steven Pinker,
as, as potentially, you know, falling into some of
those traps that we talked about, he, he doesn't
really do the, the level of parasocial cultivation, um,
that we are, uh, talking about, so that's, I
mean, there's other features, maybe Matt, you have some
that you want to, I mentioned that that I
might have missed, but, but that's, that's really what
it is, like we, we viewed it as a
way to, um, keep us on track, that we
would, um, keep a record, basically for all the
people that we covered to the extent they do
it, and they don't do it all to the
same degree. It's, it's more like a family resemblance
category, you know, when they're all, all these features
are high, you do have very likely, uh, a
secular guru or a cult leader, um, but, uh,
some of them are doing, Uh, some of them,
but not all of them, and that kind of
thing, so it's, it's on a continuum.
Right, right. Um, I mean, it's interesting because particularly
when it comes to anti-establishment attitudes, sometimes they seem
to combine with grievance mongering in certain academics that
have decided to abandon academia. I mean, I'm thinking
of people like, for example, Brett Weinstein and others
who, I mean, they, Sort of present themselves as
people who have this sort of um and again
connecting to another feature revolutionary theories about, I don't
know, in the biology, medicine, I mean whatever kind
of area it is and then they just go
on podcasts or go on to create their own
podcasts or go on other platforms. Claiming that the
entire establishment, I don't know, the entire biology community,
the entire medicine community or whatever other kind of
community, that they are wrong or at least they're
wrong in a particular aspect or in a particular
topic, and they know the actual truth. It's just
that people, because they're sort of these. Cabal to
silence alternative voices. I mean, people in academia just
want to protect the status quo and so they
don't listen to them, and but they have the
truth and other people outside of academia who are
more sensible or something like that should listen to
them. But in fact, I mean, the issue is
that The sort of theory or hypothesis or even
papers that they tried to publish for the most
part were just not that great, and that's the
reason why they are and weren't taken seriously. It's
not because there's this massive conspiracy in academia to
silence, to silence alternative voices, right.
Yeah, yeah. And, uh, Brett Weinstein and his brother
Eric, are, are, are perfect examples. They, they ding
pretty much every one of our barometer features, and
you did a good job there, Ricardo, I think,
um, running through most of the main ways. And
it's quite, uh, ironic, they have a, they have
an interesting relationship with the establishment, oftentimes. So, uh,
on one hand, they, as you said, have a
kind of a, a conspiratorial and grievance laden backstory.
Which is that they've been exiled from the institutions
because their ideas were too dangerous, too exciting, too
real for the institutions to handle, um, so they're
connecting directly to the people, and um some of
them talk about sort of doing their science or
research. Like through their podcasting or their YouTube videos
or whatever, which is, kind of laughable, right, that
that just literally isn't how. Um, uh, EVOLUTIONARY biology
or physics research or any kind of research actually
happens. So on, on one hand they seem very
thirsty to be, to be recognized by institutions, um,
like Eric, uh, Weinstein for instance, recently. Um, YOU
know,
I mean sometimes they claim they should have won
Nobel Nobel Prizes.
Indeed, indeed, sometimes whole families, uh, Eric, his brother,
and, uh, Heather Haying, his, his wife all should
have, no, no, not his wife, it's Eric's wife,
Helen attributed.
Yes, oh, poor Heather, poor Heather, um. But, but
in any case, um, yeah, so they, they seem
to very much want to, uh, be recognized. They,
um, Eric has called for, uh, you know, rich
philanthropists to basically fund, you know, $500,000 professorial, uh,
chairs for, for him, for, uh, who, who else,
uh, Jordan Peterson, uh, basically him and his friends
should be given a whole bunch of money to,
to do the really important sciences because in his
mind, They have proven that they are the only
real scientists and intellectuals living and as you said,
if you actually look at their track record, they've
produced, like next to nothing in in terms of
of outputs that um have been recognized or indeed
should be recognized. Um, SO on one hand, they
will portray universities and the other institutions as, as
entirely corrupt, entirely broken, and indeed they'll sometimes work
to create alternative versions of their institutions. Jordan Peterson
has his various academies and so on that people
can, can, can study in. Um, THEY say it's
all broken, it's all corrupt, it's all a bit
invaded by wokeness or whatever the, or whatever the,
the, the bad thing is. Um, BUT they're also
very keen for recognition, like they, they very much
make a big deal about their elite, um, credentials,
uh, that at least that's how they, uh, portray
them, and take every opportunity that they can to
remind the audience that they, of, of, of whatever
kind of, um, recognition or standing that they might
be able to point to. So it, it's an
interesting, uh, kind of relationship, and I think it
parallels like a, You know, everybody knows Donald Trump
and everyone knows the dynamic there, and there's an
interesting way in which they get to have their
cake and eat it too, cos on one hand,
populists like Donald Trump, um, demonize the elites, uh,
demonize, frankly, the most of the institutions, um, but
at the same time, Donald Trump is signaling, both
that he is a man of the people, and
speaks directly for the people and is draining the
swamp and, and stands against, These, these so-called elites,
but, but is also, you know, is the most
elite person you can imagine, he's got like gold
plated, you know, uh fixtures for God's sake. So,
um, yeah, so it's an interesting, uh, sort of
populist dynamic in terms of both being anti-elite, while
also part of the appeal is for them to
lean into their elite membership at the same time.
And there's a tendency for them to begin to
get very upset whenever, like they, Uh, people that
operate in this role will spend an inordinate amount
of time just shitting on institutions, often once they're
associated as well, right? And then, um, like in
Jordan Peter's, uh, Jordan Peterson's case, he hadn't taught
at the university in nearly a decade, right, um,
but had still retained his position, and they moved
him to an emeritus position, which, you know, actually
quite nice of them, right, because it's not like
he was ever going to. Um, BE at the
university again, um, while he was working as a,
you know, a pundit for the, the Daily Wire,
um, and, and doing his tours and all that
kind of thing, and he was enraged at that,
right? Like, he, he wrote a, uh, penned like
a very strong, uh, public letter chastising the university,
you know, for, for daring to do that, and
Sabine uh Hassenfelder, a, a YouTube, um, figure who
comments on physics. And and has taken a bit
of a turn herself towards, um, like, physics populists,
as some people have dubbed it. Um, BUT, uh,
she too spends a lot of her time just
explaining how all the physics institutions are moribund, that
people are not doing interest in physics, nobody's funding
good research, nobody's interested in good questions, and she,
and she, and she claims that for the past
few decades, Uh, bits of theoretical physics like, uh,
quantum mechanics and I think more specifically string theory
has been just a complete waste of money or
something.
So there's a, there's a common like distaste for
string theory, it's, it's a popular like punch bag
for people, but she had her uh affiliation with
some institute, you know, kind of like I have
an affiliation with Oxford because I was a, Researcher
there and have, you know, like a, an, an
email address attached with them, but they, uh, you
know, they could remove it any year, right? Like
for whatever reason, just it, uh, it also doesn't
really mean anything, except like, you know, you can
access the library services or whatever. But she again,
released the YouTube video, you know, saying, I'm being
attacked, this is, but, you know, and again, her
full-time position now is YouTuber, and that's mainly what
she spends her time. But they're allowed to critique
institutions uh as very, very strongly and imply that
the people in it are corrupt narcissists. And when
institutions, you know, say, well, this kind of damages
our reputation, maybe we don't want you using us
as like the cudgel to give yourself credibility, they're,
they get extremely upset, so it's just like this
double standard where they are free. And indeed should
be like listened to by more people to, to
criticize everyone else in mainstream institutions, mainstream theories and
so on. But any pushback immediately reveals the conspiracy
and like er the plan against them, so there's
just, there is this unbelievable level of double standard
in, in almost everything that the secular gurus do,
and it's, it's quite impressive, really.
No, no, yeah, I, I mean it, it's curious
because it seems that's, uh, I mean, I'm not
sure about all of them, but at least some
of them seem to be. DO not like to
be held accountable, and I mean they don't like
to really for the proper standards, academic standards to
be applied to them because many times what they
are complaining about is not people as they claim,
trying to suppress them or their opinion or their
ideas, but actually I don't know, people from academic
journals, people from their academic institutions just trying to
tell them, OK, so you should be more careful
about what you say on social media. You should
be more careful about making this or that type
of claim that is not supported by the evidence.
I mean, you wrote this paper, you should try
to change this or that part of the paper
because that's not proper writing or proper science, something
like that. But, but, but then they pick on
those things and run with them and they make,
make up these huge concerns. Conspiracy theories about how
the entire establishment just wants to suppress their genius
ideas when some, when many times it's just, yeah,
you're not doing a proper job. I mean you
should write better papers, you should do better research,
you should be more. I mean, you should try
to uh to be a little bit more, uh,
I, I don't, I don't, I don't know, I'm
missing the word here, but you should um be
held up to the stand uh uh to the
standards of academia and you just don't want to
do it and then you exit academia just to
go on. Podcasts and elsewhere spewing your ideas where
there's no one to hold you accountable. So, and
I mean sometimes they make a huge conspiracy theory
out of what are just normal academic, uh, procedures,
I guess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean, a perfect example of
that is the, um, um, uh, Eric or Brett
pointing to papers that are rejected from a journal
that they submitted. And uh pointing to this immediately
as evidence of, of a conspiracy because of course,
there can't be anything wrong with their paper. Their
paper has to be the absolute best thing that
has ever been done. I mean, and you know
it's, it's interesting that that works, I mean, you
know, as a working academic myself I've published, Hundreds
of papers in academic journals. Just, just, uh, yesterday
I've been working on one where we had a
bad run. It's been rejected 4 times from different
journals. And that's entirely normal. It's, it's actually, it's
a good paper, I do believe so. Um, YOU
know, the comments and stuff are quite, maybe a
little bit harsh, a little bit pernickety, but we've
taken, we've taken them seriously and working to make
a better paper. That's just, that's just, that's just
normal academic functioning. Um, SO you can see how
a lot of these gerometer dimensions kind of dovetail
with each other. Like if you are a, a
narcissistic person who has this inflated idea about every
idea you've had, every, every paper you've written is
just, is just the best thing since sliced bread,
then you're gonna be more prone to react like
that, uh, it, rather than, um, you know, work
to, to sort of improve and take the, the
negative feedback seriously, but, It's connected also to this,
these narratives of grievance, cos obviously little incidents like
the, like that which are mundane and mean nothing,
get folded into a backstory, where they are being
persecuted, where they are suffering for the great moral
stance and the amazing ideas that they've had, and
that again dovetails with the sort of cultishness that
we're talking about, the kind of affiliation, because that's
exactly the kind of story that is emotive, like
if you, if you accept it, if you accept
their version. Of events, then you accept that they
are a genius, they are being persecuted for doing
the right thing and trying to make the world
a better place and the institutions are holding them
down, so it's the kind of thing you're gonna
feel sympathy with and want to get on board
this kind of moral crusade that they are off
and on. So, um, it's interesting the way in
which these different um aspects of the barometer connect,
uh, together, um. Yeah.
No, and it's, and sometimes it's a bit sad
because for example, in the case of Jordan Peterson,
at least as far as I know what I
read from his academic work, he was doing actually
a proper, he was doing good work when it
comes. To, for example, personality psychology and studying alcohol
addiction and all of that. I mean, I've even
interviewed, for example, one of his students, Colin D.
Young, and he's also been doing a great, uh,
great work in personality psychology and uh people who
studied under Jordan Peterson, some of them have great
things to say about him, and they are proper
academics. It's just that it seems that Jordan Peterson
could not stay in his lane. I mean, for
him it seemed like, OK, just doing a proper
personality psychology. I mean, I, I, I'm, I'm more
than that. I mean, I. I have to do
more than that because I'm a better and more,
I should be more more prominent figure than just
a a professor at the University of Toronto doing
good personality psychology.
I, I might have some pushback around the level
of quality of his psychology research. Oh,
OK, so I'm, I'm not saying that I'm like
very well familiarized. It seemed to be good, but
it's
better than 12 Hours for Life. I'll give it
that, but I think in terms of like his
previous research, I suspect his Co-authors deserve a lot
of the credit for some of the more empirical
work, and Jordan's contribution, I think, is more towards
the speculative Jungian side. So if you like that
sort of thing, then maybe if you're, you'll find
I do know, but I, but I do know
that when he previously, and, and this is the
case with many of the people that we've covered,
when they begin. They are often a lot more
circumspect about the statements that they make, and they
gradually, as their audience grows bigger, and the attention
they receive and, and the topics they're asked to
respond to expand, that I think what Matt talked
about, the, the kind of narcissistic personality type takes
over. And they get um kind of carried away
by their own myth. Now, I think in most
cases, the people that we've looked at, actually, when
you go back and look at their pre-frame. Uh,
HISTORY, there's actually significant warning signs, um, and there
are behaviors which are unusual, like just to take
one for Jordan Peterson, when he was asked to
submit an IRB for one of his research in
the University of Toronto, he railed against that uh
somebody without a PhD like him should have any
position on a panel that assesses it, right? HE
demanded to see the board. And to like ask
why they have the right to assess the validity
of his research, right? Now, that's not normal, right,
that's, and that, that was chalked up to him
being, you know, a, a kind of unusual and,
and like kind of passionate figure, right, very bombastic
and all that kind of stuff, but I think
that speaks to the features that we're talking about,
but it, but it is the case in certain,
Examples of people that we've covered that they actually
do have a body of legitimate work that they've
published. Um, MOST of the gurus, it's fair to
say, do not, but, but in certain cases, they,
they do. And what often happens there is like
there are original. Work is, it, it can even
be influential in a particular field, right, in a
particular area, but they then, uh, veer very far
from there and speak with like the same level
of confidence across like topics that they know. Nothing,
um, about or, or, or very little, so it's,
uh, it's not always the case that like a
track record of publications and research, papers like there's
a, a fellow called Peter McCulloch, who was influential
during the COVID pandemic, he's a, a physician, but
he has published a large amount of, Papers, but
he became one of the primary figures promoting ivermectin
conspiracies, right? And in that case, does that mean
all of his previous research was, was bad and
unreliable? Like, no, it, it, it doesn't, right, but,
uh, if you see how he behaved during the
pandemic, it was definitely in the role of like
an anti-vaccine conspiracy theorist, um, so, Yeah, it's, they're
not all completely fraudulent, um, but I, but I
think their legitimate work is often, uh, like a
lot less revolutionary than, than they will present it
as, as being later, and, um, yeah, that's, that's
just like a caveat I'd, I'd keep in mind.
No, yeah, and I mean for sure when it
comes to Jordan Peterson, at the very least his
classes, I mean the courses he taught at the
University of Toronto were really, really bad. I mean,
I watched some of the classes and they were
all over the place and there was very little
scientific rigor there. I mean, One time he was
talking about, I know Jung, and then he suddenly
moved to mythology and suddenly he was talking, he
inserted that BS about how people from certain societies
through the use of psychedelics were seeing the DNA
double elixir. It's like what is this? It's all
over the place. Is this a university class. Come
on.
There's actually the, the guy that hired Jordan Peterson,
or, or was like pivotal in getting him to
the University of Toronto actually mentioned that, you know,
the things that attracted to him originally as a
candidate, that he, he was this kind of, you
know, big ideas guy who would connect all these
divergent topics and, and, and charismatic and so on,
like a, a bit of a renegade, right, within
the field, were appealing, but then, Uh, as time
went on, and there were like some concerns around
his lectures and stuff, when people sat in, they
noticed exactly what you said, that like, he mixed
in completely valid and, and like well supported theories
with these, you know, grand expositions, and, and like
idiosyncratic interpretations of religious beliefs, and, In a melange,
where if you're an undergraduate student, you were receiving
them all, you know, like, and, and that's something
that we see with a lot of the gurus
is that they, they're often like uh teaching or
making reference to valid theories or, you know, established
research, and they Use that kind of baseline to
establish credibility, and then they leap from there into
like the, these really elaborate schemes and, and like
extreme extrapolations, but when you push them, they just
point back to the, like established literature, as if
that means that their extrapolation is true and like
it, it, it doesn't follow, so. Um, YEAH, that's,
that's part of the reason we find them interesting
is they're often quite slippery like that, like a
figure we covered recently was Iain McGilchrist, um, that
some of your listeners might know. Oh,
that, that, that, uh, um, I, I mean, uh,
the, the brain guy, right? I mean,
realization,
the, the atmosphere is the left hemisphere, right hemisphere
guy, right?
Yeah, and, and I, if he's known by people.
Well he's generally known, and I would say, you
know, just in the ether by me and Matt
before we focused on him, as somebody that like
might have these, uh, like quite idiosyn idiosyncratic interpretations,
but he's rock solid when it comes to the
neuroscience literature and stuff, so, and our experience of
uh looking at his content was, that is not,
that is not the case at all. Like he,
he is miss. Representing the neuroscience literature very badly,
and then from there, leaping into like massive extrapolations
like that society is left or right-brained in different
eras and, and, and so on, and that this
proves kind of the, uh, that determinism and materialism
is false as well, like he has a whole
bunch of things attached to it, but the basic
thing is his underlying representation of. IS inaccurate and,
and actually fairly misleading, but that's not his reputation,
and he is invited to give lectures at, you
know, prestigious institutions and uh for like various debates
and stuff regularly. So, um, yeah, just, just, it,
it, it seems that it's not a barrier to
completely misrepresent the scientific consensus of the topic either.
OK, but let's be, let's be fair to Jordan
Peterson. I mean, don't you find it fun to
listen to 30 minutes of a guy interpreting the
Lion, The Lion King through a Jungian and pseudo
evolutionary psychology lens and saying that, OK, now really
made Simba. Become a man because boys are afraid
of girls and they have to grow up to
really meet up girls' expectations. I mean, come on,
it's fun, right?
Yeah, no, it is, it is fun, and that's
part of, that's part of what we, uh, enjoy
looking at it. I guess if you, if you
treat it as very much as light entertainment and,
and nothing else, then enjoy, that, that would be
our recommendation, um. Yeah, um, but, uh, you know,
they, they are very much, um, big picture thinkers,
very intuitive, very conceptual, um, like we, we cover
a group called the, well, we call it, well
they call themselves sense makers, um, and they're, they're
in, they're in a similar kind of vein, and
it's interesting, and you know, Ian McGilchrist is in,
in that group too. And you can sort of
see them hop around from idea to idea and
connecting things just on the fly, um, so it's,
it's almost like a form of beat, jazz, poetry,
you know, sometimes, sometimes I, uh, uh, I think
that some of these people might have a sort
of schizoid personality because they are making associations between,
I, I mean across everything else.
That thought has occurred to me too.
I, I, I think one of the things about
that though is like, it's often, um, like, enjoyable,
the metaphors and stuff that they go on, or
the, the like interpret interpretation of Pinocchio, right? But,
but often what, what comes up when you're enjoying
it, is you're, you're enjoying this like connections and
the claims that it very often connects to the
Bible, right, and, And these kind of things, but
the yellow, the more of the content that you
consume, the more that you also see, it often,
very often, Uh, connects to like a particular political,
uh, worldview, and a set of themes, which are
like, extremely repetitive, like so with Jordan Peterson, for
example, almost everything that he talks about, he will,
uh, relate to the concept of verticalness, like things
going up and orientating towards higher things, and, And,
and you can, you can do it for almost
anything, and he does do it for almost everything.
And then he connects that, he uses that to
say, like, orientating yourself upwards, is like orientating yourself
towards God and the heavens, and therefore, everything is
ultimately connected to like religion, and you will often
find that each of the, like, little gurus or
sense makers, they have their own. Sets of concepts
that they like to play with, and they will
talk to each other, but they're mainly not really
listening to each other, they're, they're just waiting for
an opportunity to say, yes, and that's why it
connects to the vertical, right, or, you know, whatever
the case, the other one might be. So, uh,
Matt and I still have a perverse enjoyment of
listening to like people spend 3 hours talk about
metaphors together. Um, AND, and go on these journeys,
but it does get incredibly repetitive the more you
listen to the content, because the same themes just
repeat over and over, and it's, it's very often
is tied to justifying, um, conservative anti-immigrant, um, positions.
And you know, whatever your political views are, uh,
on, you know, what should be the correct immigration
policy or whatever, that's one thing, but it's just
like, it's not being sold. As if it's like
a political ideology, but it almost always is pushing
a very specific political line, and it's, yeah, it's
frankly like annoying because you're like, it would be
a lot more enjoyable if it was just about
like Pinocchio and interpreting the symbols and stuff, but
it's always like Pinocchio means that Christianity is the
best religion and we should reduce immigration into the
West.
Yeah, I mean, but, but some of these things
seem to be at least partly genetic because they
seem to run in the family, because Mikaela Peterson
also has these, some of these tendencies, and I
mean every time she comes up with BS about
the lion diet or something like that, as. Supposedly
we should all just eat meat or beef specifically.
I, I, I don't know why the obsession with
beef. I mean, why not chicken? Why not pork?
I mean, why don't,
they each have their own specific animal that they
only consume, I believe his wife only consumes ruminant
meat, uh, so, uh.
But I, but I mean, I, I don't, I
don't get it why people just make this stuff
up about how supposedly during the Pleistocene women, uh
uh not women, humans just ate meat and uh
uh and I mean even in agricultural societies, apparently,
uh, the adaptations that we evolved, uh, um, by,
uh, I mean through millennia of living in agricultural
societies. I mean to process cereal, milk, uh, eggs,
beer and all of that, apparently that doesn't matter
either, so. Yeah.
Yeah, well, uh, you know, I think that's a
good example of where the, the guru stuff can
intersect with other things, like so there's, there's health
and wellness woo, which includes diet fads. It's obviously
its own thing, right? You, you know, the diet
fads have been around for, for, for, for so
long and there is any number of weird, Health
beliefs that that are incredibly popular because, somehow our,
our health and, and being, you know, like living
longer, um avoiding disease and avoiding, you know, being
sick is, is somehow an existential concern. That kind
of gets all of our juices flowing and seems
to prone most people for being quite quick to
take up non-evidence based beliefs. So, anti-vax is obviously
the poster child, um it's, it's it's almost like.
The anti-Semitism of the health and wellness world, right?
It just keeps popping up. Uh, IT'S perennial. But,
um, but there's just something about eating as well,
like the, you know, the choosing what to put
in your mouth, it's a very intimate choice or
whatever. It seems to, seems to trigger their, um,
almost Freudian, uh, issues. I don't know.
Yeah, and sadly for the genetic explanation, the nature
and nurture, Jordan Peterson's wife also does the same
thing. And, and we listen to Michaela's content and
there's a whole ecosystem, and they, they're all eating
very specific different types of fruit or, or maybe
somebody is just eating like a type of berry
or whatever. They, they all have like their specific
things, but, but the carnivore diet is, um, Yeah,
it had its a moment there and, and still
does amongst some red pill communities, but it hasn't
done Jordan Peterson any figures, like he, he's currently
out of commission in case you haven't noticed, um,
due to, I believe, two diagnoses ago from Akila,
it was toxic mold perhaps infused by demons. It
was demon, um, infused toxic mold, but I believe
now it is, um, Uh, symptoms from taking, uh,
medications to wean yourself off, uh, addictive drugs, the
side effects have emerged after 5 years, maybe triggered
by the toxic mold. So yeah,
because, because apparently he, I don't know how many
years ago, 6 years ago, perhaps he was abusing
benzodiazepines, benzodiazepines,
and then he, uh, He took himself off them
at Mala's advice by Uh, putting himself in an
induced coma in,
uh, and he, and he went, he went to
Russia, right?
Yeah, yeah, I, I, I, it's one of those
things where like when you hear it, it, it
doesn't quite land like what that, because, you know,
to me, induced coma, it sounds like, you know,
it, it sounds quite severe, but like when you
think about it, it's actually like putting someone unconscious,
right, for several days and keeping them in a
medically induced coma while They don't go through physical
withdrawal for, for drugs, and there's a reason that
generally, you know, in, in Canada, where they were,
that they wouldn't recommend doing that. And actually, according
to Michaela and Jordan, when he came out of
that, he had brain damage, um, as a result
of the, the treatment they, they presented that, you
know, as kind of the treatment or the addiction
or whatever the case, um, was. But, but it's
certainly the case that like after he returned to
public life after that, he. He was remarkably less
stable. He, he was crying in, in almost every
public appearance, and he became like, uh, he, he
always was, you know, very aggressive and shouty, but,
but like more emotion prone and stuff in, in
appearances. So, you know, I, I don't know, but
in any case, all of the various, um, health
approaches and restrictive diets, they don't seem to have
done them any good, um, with, so. Maybe, maybe
there's other things at play there psychologically.
Yeah, I mean, I actually thought that if it
was true, because, you know, sometimes it's actually hard
to figure out if they're actually telling the truth
or not, but if it was true that for
the past several years, Jordan Peterson was on a
carnivore diet, I think there's also a very good
chance that he was missing some essential nut. Is
there, I mean, because come on, you have to
eat vegetables, you have to eat apparently not a
little, you have to eat a little bit of
carbohydrates, right?
I mean they are, they are prone to exaggeration,
like Jordan Peterson, I think on one of his
appearances for Joe Rogan claimed to have been awake
for 27 days straight after drinking a glass of
apple cider, so. There are, um, there are various
games that you have to take with a pinch
of salt. And, and actually, that was one of
the things he was allowed to consume. Yes, he
said that he was eating exclusively steak, I think
salt and salt and sparkling, sparkling water and the
high-end toothpicks as well. I mean, not consuming them,
presumably, but this was something he was chewing on,
which again, I don't know, it just doesn't sound
like the healthiest lifestyle, so. Um, YEAH, but that,
that he has made so many health claims, and,
and this is one of a, a common thing
like Matt said that often the gurus will have,
um, if not lines of supplements that they're hawking,
they, they will often have very bad. Heuristics when
it comes to medicines and, and health, right, and
they, they tend to like be very susceptible to
anti-vaccine narratives and, and that kind of thing, not
all of them, but it, but it is a
common thing because, you know, the obvious thing is
the system is lying. Uh, THERE'S a, a truth
which they're trying to suppress. Joe Rogan and the
alternative media are, are, you know, trying to get
it out there. So, actually, like Joe Rogan, part
of his whole thing when he promoted the anti-vaccine
thing was because he was listening to, um, gurus
like Brett Weining. Einstein, right, on the, the topic,
so they can have a very pernicious influence on,
on health, um, when they're uh heated on these
topics, and in the middle of a pandemic, they
are like a deadly effect on, on public health.
Yeah, but it's funny because at the same time
that Joe Rogan was promoting anti-vaxxer content. I mean,
when he got, when he was diagnosed with COVID,
uh, when he got COVID, he Physically took a
cocktail of different medications, so I, I mean, OK,
so vaccinations are or vaccines are big pharma, but
then a cocktail of different medications, that's not big
pharma.
I
mean,
yeah, yeah, yeah, I mean you can see the
parallels there, right, because um I guess these, these
uh influencers and their audience like to think of
themselves as incredibly unique. Incredibly special people, like not,
not part of the flock, not part of the
herd, and I think there is something about the
bog standard, universal health treatments that I think just
rubs them the wrong way, the the idea that
they just get the same thing as everyone else,
and that there's nothing super special, so you see
them, With these obsessions about health and their need
for incredibly bespoke diets, um, there's an exact parallel
there, I think with the attraction for someone like
Joe Rogan, who will pay happily, you know, thousands
of dollars for, you know, uh, uh, just, just,
um, a week or whatever it is for, for
one of these cocktails, and it's just, you know,
crammed full of weird things, as you said, probably
produced in laboratories just as artificial, whatever,
but it's it's. He had monoclonal antibodies as part
of it, which is, you know, it's it's a
valid treatment, it's extremely expensive,
and by the way, they're always complaining that I
mean mainstream medications are just big pharma trying to
make money out of it, but they don't complain
when the The supplement industry makes billions around the
world and through medication that is not properly regulated
or tested.
I would, I would also mention on that point,
that it doesn't get mentioned enough that on it,
where Joe Rogan was a, uh, like. I can't
remember his exact role, whether he was like an
early investor or a spokesperson or somebody, but he
had a senior role in on it, this, this
supplement company which he promoted Alpha Brain and various
other things on this podcast. It, it was sold
to Unilever for, uh, undisclosed, but estimated to be,
you know, it, it, at least in the tens
of millions, if not hundreds of millions deal, um.
And that's selling like a, a supplement company to
a transnational corporation, and Joe Rogan, right, is one
of the senior people in it. And I mean,
all that, that should, should, doesn't that count as,
as somebody earning money, right, like for hawking their
audience supplements or, or collaborating with, you know, corporations
and so on, but somehow that kind of thing
just, that never counts, it's, it's only, You know,
mainstream medicine, so even if you have like Peter
Hotez, for example, the uh figure in America who
worked to make like low cost uh vaccines available,
right, so the profit motive isn't there, but he
was cast as a villain by Joe Rogan and,
um, the anti-vaccine community, right, because he's trying to
make low-cost vaccines available um to developing countries and
stuff, so.
Yeah, it's an
incredible,
it's an incredible trick like Joe Rogan is a
perfect example, like getting back to that notion of
the elite, right, or someone on the inside, right,
he's, he's rich, right, he's got interests in financial,
direct financial interests in a lot of these things.
I mean he's a he's a centimillaire at this
point,
right? Yeah, he had a 100 million deal with
Spotify alone without all the ads.
Yeah, and so, so massive conflicts of interests in,
in, in, in many ways, but, but very similar
to Donald Trump. Like the branding is that he's,
he's an everyman, right? He's, he's just, he's just
Joe Rogan, he's just a guy, he's just talking
about stuff, he's just like you, right, so, um,
but the business model, uh, speaks, speaks differently, so
I think there's a strong analogy there again with,
With Donald Trump and that you, you can seemingly
have a kind of anti-institutional, an anti-elite kind of
and present yourself as a completely independent figure untainted
by any kind of other interests apart from just
being a genuine guy. And where the reality can
be the exact opposite, it doesn't seem to matter.
Yeah, I also find it funny how many of
those guys have this sort of cop out where,
I mean, if someone confronts them with a claim
that they made that is not supported by the
evidence, they just say, oh, I'm just asking questions.
I mean, I'm just exploring ideas, something like that,
which Curiously enough, seems to be something that is
very attractive to certain types of people who say,
oh yeah, I'm just interested in the truth, so
this guy right here, I mean, yes, like different
ideas and I kind of like ideas. It's like
a sort of Dave, Dave Rubin kind of attitude.
Oh, I'm just, I mean, I'm into ideas, ideas,
you know, stuff like that.
There's a Well, there's a, a kind of symbiotic
relationship where these secular guru figures will constantly reaffirm
to their audience that they are critical thinkers, they're
free thinkers, they are people willing to hear different
perspectives and so on. But they are very, very
strongly reactive to hearing critical voices. We know, right,
because we have a podcast dedicated to producing critical
content, um, uh, around those figures, and Universally, they
do not respond well to that, right? And, and
their audience, by and large, do not like it
either. There's a couple of, uh, very few, but
there's a couple of exceptions that I can think
of where people are receptive to it, but, um,
it's, it is this kind of pantomime, where people
are presented as, as constantly, Uh, being free, free,
free thinking members of like the, you know, the
public exchange of ideas, but the, it, it's within
a very controlled atmosphere, and basically, if you want
to be a member of that club, you have
to be very circumspect in your criticism, and you
have to be overall, very, like, um, congratulatory and,
and praising. Of the other person's ideas. So, you
can disagree, but you have to frame it that
the other person is a very important thinker, and
that you're both like doing a great service to
the public discourse by having your, you know, discussion
in person. And, uh, yeah, Matt and I have
often noted, right, like, you know, not that we
don't have any illusions about academia, right, that academia
is always this productive thing where people aren't just
having conferences where They're waffling or, or doing papers
that are, you know, making minor contributions, myself and
included, right? Pushing numbers around the spreadsheets, or whatever
the case might be. But the thing is that
they really present what they're doing as so much
more grandiose and important, and that, and they give
people, I think people who often feel that they've
been overlooked or they didn't have the chance to
get, like, Education, or, you know, they wanted to
do a PhD but they never did, and now
they are being told by people, those guys all
look down on you, the whole system is corrupt
anyway, this is actually a replacement for university level
education, this conversation, you're listening to, and look at
all these figures, right, you have a philosopher here,
and you have a neuroscientist, and you have a
biologist, and we are here having the kind of
conversations you were never supposed to hear. And there's
something very appealing about that for the audience, and
I, I think anybody coming from the outside and
saying, that guy's talking shit, like, you're, you're not
going to be received well, because it just punctures
the illusion. That this is anything more than, you
know, like, like what you talked about earlier, it's
like, it, it can be fun and indulgent and
enjoyable to listen to people, you know, speculate on
big ideas, but it's not science, and it's not
academic, and it's not building robust theories, and they
present it very much, that's what they're doing. They're
like refining their theories, one podcast at a time,
but nothing ever changes. It's always the same conversation
just with different figures.
Yeah, by the way, talking about academia, what do
you make of the heterodox people? I mean, what
kinds, I mean, do you think that there are
perhaps some points where they are right, but I
mean, more, more broadly, I don't, I want to
hear your thoughts on this because I think that
at least some of them. I mean they seem,
or apparently at the beginning they seem to start
with good intentions like just pointing to some biases,
particularly political biases that maybe are. Prevalent in academia
or at least in certain parts of academia, but
then it seems to turn into just people who
are saying that for example, oh if If people
are denying the reality of race, if there's no
scientific racism in academia, if, if there's no, I
don't know, eugenics in academia, I mean, usually it's
far right ideas, then it's because they are suppressed
by the far, far left, the radical left, the
wokes or whatever term they use. Before it was
SJWs, I, I mean, what, uh, I mean, do,
do you, um, OK, so what do you think
about the orthodox people and do you think that
perhaps there's something to that idea that maybe at
a certain point they're just trying to inject particular
political ideas into academia even if they don't have
any scientific credibility.
Yeah, I think, um, I think in principle, the
idea is great, right? Um, A a diversity of
views, um, um, being, uh, you know, not being
constrained by some kind of orthodoxy and being able
to contemplate different directions. I'm totally in favor of
that and I'd uh even concede that I think,
uh, you know, I'm, I'm, I'm a liberal left
wing person myself, but I think academia, you know.
It's such a, it's such a progressive liberal place
that that can bleed into a lot of different
disciplines and just affect how, you know, the kind
of, the kind of hypotheses and theories and things
that, that get, that gain traction. Like for instance,
in my field, I, my day to day job
is working in gambling research and addiction. And there
are just, it's, it's quite clear that there are
some perspectives that are more popular and some topics
that are more popular because of that sort of
bent. So in principle, I think it's good. In
practice, very, very little has come, come out of
that good that I can tell, because the, the
difficulty, I, I remember looking at like the program
for some heterodox journal or uh, uh, you know,
table of contents or the subconference and things like
that and, And it was just a grab bag
of weird nonsense as far as I could tell,
because it's, it's, it's very hard to, it's very
hard to have, like you can't just have OK,
these, these ideas are different, these are, you know,
they have to be good ideas as well. Um,
SO, um, I think, I, I think um I
think at least some people in, in that movement
are probably, I think had, have good intentions, but
it's, um, you know, but for some it's just,
oh they, they wanna do the opposite. Of, of
the, the woke kind of thing, they like they
wanna inject, I think bad ideas, you know, and
you know very reactionary ideas into academia. Um, BUT
I think, I think any of them just suffer
from the problem that it's very difficult to sort
of initiate such a program of just creating more
heterodoxy. Um, WHAT, what do you think, Chris?
I, I think that, yeah, I, I agree that
in principle, I, I, I'm fully in support of
like, you know, welcoming people with diverse perspectives. And,
and that kind of thing, including people that are
more conservative or, or more religious or whatever the
case might be, right? But, um, I also think
that a lot of the solutions to what they
claim to care about are resolved by things like
the open science movement and pre-registration and registered reports
and uh just, Any of the open science transparency
things, right, you're, you're making your hypotheses clear, you're,
or you're working in adversarial collaborations, uh, to design
studies, all these kind of things, and yet there's
almost no interest that I see from a lot
of people in the heterodox movement towards that, not
universally, there are people in the heterodox movement that
are also pro-op science and so on, but, but
the level of interest is surprisingly low, right, given,
That is the goal, and to me, that is
the solution, right, because if you, if you have
things where people's, uh, like, they, they have the
studies and the hypotheses are set out, and they're,
um, like transparently available, they can't move things and
so on, then you're, you're kind of, you know,
at least on the track to making the research
better and more robust. And so, if it turns
out that there There's a result which is not
aligned with like, political convictions, it will show up
in the results, right? And yes, there is a
way that you can frame things and you can
measure things, and, you know, I think some of
the complaints about like left-wing authoritarianism, for example, being
like a, a topic that was a little bit
taboo in the psychology discipline, like there, there's validity
to those points, but often, like Matt says, the
unfortunate thing is that I often find myself, Like,
in, in agreement about the criticisms of the biases
of the mainstream academic discipline, and, and, you know,
the liberal bias that, that exists to a certain
extent. But then the people who are doing the
corrective, they're often importing, like the opposite bias, uh,
and sometimes like in a very direct and strong
way. And the, the uh conference that Matt was
talking about was, there was one. Um, HELD in
the UK I think recently there was like, uh,
how to reform heterodoxy in academia like 2.0 or
this kind of thing. Half the speakers, or almost
half the speakers were figures like Ganad and Chris
Ruffo and, Uh, you know, and, and not Marjorie
Taylor Greene, but it was, there were some other
politician figures that were, you know, the same kind
of people, and you're like, what do they know
about running good research and stuff, and, and Steven
Pinker and some other people were there, and they
might have, you know, valid things to say, but
when the other speakers like reform candidate Matthew Goodwin,
I'm, I'm kind of like, Yeah, I don't think
he is the person to listen to for methodological
reform, given he's conducted a bunch of like polls
and stuff in recent terms that are very, very
bad. So, um, I'm all for methodological reform and
for attempting to make things more objective and reliable,
and to have more diversity of voices and, and
not crowd out things because of political points of
view. But I, I think the modern heterodox movement.
Is, uh, often like let down by having a,
a kind of political activist agenda that's a mile
wide, so that's the thing, I, I generally say
that I, I would consider myself like heterodox sympathetic,
but when I think about the heterodox movement and
the people online identifying as heterodox, I'm like, Jesus
Christ. So, yeah, that's the, yeah, that's the kind
of, in principle, great, uh in practice. Less great,
but um,
yeah, I mean in, in, in short, Ricardo, two
wrongs don't make a right, right? You, if, if,
if there, if, if there is some left wing
bias in academia, the solution isn't to introduce right
wing bias, right, the solution is. Is to bring
us more to getting, getting that kind of political
and activist kind of mentality away from the idea
of just being curious and wanting to know the
correct answers to things and gathering data and as
Chris said, good methodologies like from the open science
movement. It's, it's having that kind of commitment. Uh,
NOT, not the activist attitude of we're gonna, we're
gonna inject some sort of antidote to these other
ideas. Um, YEAH, that's, that's the way.
I like, I like heterodoxy as practiced by Mickeyan's
like, I'm not endorsing all of his takes because
he likes to make provocative like tweets or whatever
they are on Sub stack, but I think his
approach is in line with that where he will
often go. Against the grain of a consensus, but
then conduct good research to, like, argue the case,
right? Or to introduce, like, you know, oh, maybe
there's some relevant criticisms here. And I'm, I've no
issue when that happens. And I, I do think
there are cases where you can point to, where
there's definitely been, like, political overreach, with people being
targeted, you know, for articles and journals where they're
perceived. As like, going against a liberal consensus, and
I don't think that's a good thing. But I,
but as Matt says, I don't think the solution
is that you create, like, like pseudo-journals that just
end up publishing 90% about race and IQ and
Muslim crime statistics. Like, that's, that's not the solution.
Yeah. I,
I, I think the kind of heterodoxy you want
is another good example is Peter Singer. So, like
I, I don't, I'm not a philosopher, I don't
know whether, you know, I, I've, I've, I've read
his stuff in a very casual kind of way.
But he's a, here's an example of someone who
is very, you know, out of step, right? Say
a lot of contro, you know, has controversial positions
and is out of step with other people, but
it's, it's the, it's the good kind of diversity,
I think that, uh, you know, but it's, that's,
that, that's not a kind of figure you would
generally associate with the heterodox movement because, um, so,
yeah, I, I think, um, Yeah, I, I think
we should, um, encourage more eccentrics and, um,
and, and there, there is an editor, I think
it's like science now, um. I always pronounce her
first name wrong, but Simon Vzier, um, who, who
is like a, a big advocate for open science
and reform, and, and she's like the editor of
one of the biggest psychology journals now. So, you
know, that's the kind of thing where I'm like,
there actually is reform going on, and, and you're
seeing, you know, more pre-registered studies. More many lab
studies and so on. That's, that's what we, that's
what we want, we need in all areas of
science, like more transparency. But, but that's one of
the things that's like kind of notable to me
in listening to these gurus' content. They never ever
bring up open science or anything like that. And
it's directly relevant to what they are. You know,
claiming, uh, as the things they want to involve,
you know, secret networks and non-transparent reviews and all
these kind of things, but they just have no
interest in that entire area, so it's, it's a
weird, the only time they reference it is to
mention the replication crisis means you can't trust like
social science research at all, right? Yeah.
Yeah, no, so you, you, we are reaching our
time limit, so I have just one quick question
to ask you, and the date we're recording this
podcast on. I mean, the World Cup is still
ongoing, and so there was this one video on
your YouTube channel where you asked whether Gary Stevenson
was the Cristiano Ronaldo of economics, and I think
that you did something there that you didn't even
notice because he is the Cristiano Ronaldo of economics,
but it's It's not because he's the best economist
out there, it's because he's the most delusional economist.
Just, just to be clear, we ask that because
Gary compared himself to Cristiano Ronaldo in his own
context, so yeah, that's uh, but, but that is
an interesting point to, to make, but I, I.
I still feel like if Cristiano to Ronaldo to
football is not Dary Stevenson to economics, like his
level of achievement far outstrips.
OK, his level of achievement, I agree, but uh
uh just recently said that him winning the Euro
2016 is the same as winning the World Cup,
and uh. I mean, that's just coping hard, man.
That's
just, they, they might have similar levels of delusion.
Uh, THAT'S, that's definitely possible. That, that's, uh, yeah,
I, hard to beat Gary.
But yeah, but since you bring up Gary, he's
a good example because he's, he's, he's obviously a
left wing actor. ACTIVIST, very different from most of
the figures that we covered that are right wing,
but if you look carefully at the stuff we've
been talking about, like his constant references to his
elite background, his elite education, how he got the
best grades, how he was the best trader, but
he's also a man of the people, speaking for
the people against those elites, the system, sticking it
to them, right? Um, YOU'LL see a lot of
the same patterns, and a thing that many people
seem to struggle with is they say, well, hang
on, I agree with that message. I, I, you
know, I, I, I, I don't like billionaires. I
think we should have a more equal society. It's
like, of course you do. Nobody likes billionaires. We
all, we would all like to see a more
equal society.
Are you, are you sure about that? Are you
sure that nobody like billionaires, because I see lots
of. People on necks, people like Elon Musk's,
that's true, no, I, I was overspeaking by saying
everyone, but these are incredibly popular positions, right? And,
and, and all we'd say
even Elon Musk doesn't like other billionaires, right?
That's right, that's right, um. So you know what
we'd say is just just decouple the two things.
You can, you can agree with the general thing
that one is, is activating for, and then there's
a totally separate question which is, is this person
a credible and authoritative and useful source of information
about the topic, or are they giving you, A
simplistic paint by numbers message that is designed to
appeal to your emotions, because these are completely separate
questions. Like another good, I, I'll give you a
personal example, um, I personally am incredibly supportive of
Ukraine and I have very strong feelings on, on
that conflict, and I, I absolutely cannot stand some
of these pro-Ukraine propaganda channels, and in fact like
the even the Sun and the Telegraph run these
YouTube things. Like if you believe those channels, you'd
believe that Ukraine was on the cusp of winning
and Russia was collapsing every week for the last
4 years, right? Like it, it is stuff that
is designed to, to tap into your emotions and
provide a comforting yet inaccurate view of the, what
is a very serious issue. So I, I think
it's a direct analogy there to if you're someone
who cares about inequality. Uh, REALLY hedge billionaires, want
something done about, you know, taxation and so on
or house prices, then just think, well, is, is
this, like, is, is, is, is, this is a
separate question, like I, I feel offended when someone
is giving me inaccurate information about the Ukraine conflict
because I care about it a lot. I think
people should feel the same way about, about Gary
Stevenson and and
there's there there's also in that specific. In instance,
there is a figure that you can point to
that, you know, I don't think Gary would appreciate
the comparison, but Russell Brand, uh, you know, about
5 or 6 years ago, was very much focused
on wealth inequality, uh, addiction, and arguing against, you
know, the The kind of billionaire class and, and
all this kind of thing, and, and calling for
a left-wing revolution, right, that was, I, I mean,
it wasn't particularly well articulated, but he was going
on speaking tours with um Left-wing figures like Owen
Jones and so on, right, in the UK um
and now has completely shifted, right, to like the
right-wing populist, uh, anti-vaccine figure, and now people are
extremely skeptical, right, when he declares himself now into
Christianity, or that kind of thing, but, You should
be skeptical when he's endorsing the thing that you
like too, because, you know, wealth inequality can be
a problem, and it doesn't mean that Russell Brand
talking about it is doing, you know, that you
can't criticize him because he's talking about a real
issue. As Matt says, the two things should be
separate, but they're often not so in our audience,
people often enjoy us criticizing people that they don't
like, who are on the like political opposing team,
and then they. Very frequently, when we cover a
left wing figure or whatever, they'll say, well, it
was, it was all, you were, everything you were
doing was right until you decided to look, and
it just doesn't work. When you look at like
someone I like, the whole system falls apart. You're
like, did it? Did it really? Uh, um, YEAH,
so that's, that's, but, you know, we're, we're all
human, so we all have our, our biases and
golden cows. So that's the way it works.
Yeah, and it's, it's not that. Just that it's
not because someone is on a particular issue is
right or is on your side that you cannot
criticize them on other issues, but it's also the
fact that even if you agree that economic inequality
is a problem, you don't have to agree with
every left wing claim made about it because some
of them might just be wrong.
Yeah, or, or in that particular case he has,
he's proposing a wealth tax. Many people have said
that is not a good solution, you know, for
various practical reasons there are other solutions, and he's
kind of oversimplifying and, and in some cases, as,
as Matt pointed out, completely dismissing other. Approaches and,
and positions and say no other econ, you know,
but now he says a couple of economists, but
generally he says economists aren't allowed to talk about
inequality, they don't have any interest in it, they
don't want to address it because economists are rich,
out of touch, elite bastards, right? And you're like,
is that, there's a whole bunch of like economic
institutes focused on inequality. There's charities working on inequality,
and there's other proposals beyond a wealth tax, but,
but that's the kind of thing, right, where you
could fundamentally agree with the problem and just disagree
about, you know, the proposed solution or the implementation.
And
the other problem about, about populist messaging is because
it's so simplistic, it often misdiagnoses the problem. So
like in Australia, you know, you might have populist
anti-immigration rhetoric, and they'll point to a whole bunch
of things and point to immigrants, so the issues
they point to can be real, but because they've
misdiagnosed, The cause of it, then they're not helpful
at all. I, and if it's the case that
actually say housing prices, uh, are expensive, not because
perhaps the billionaires are buying up all of the
houses, but maybe because of certain financial incentives and,
you know, the injection of money due to COVID
and just, you know, aging population and you know
what I mean, asset prices, maybe the answer's a
bit more complicated and maybe the solution's a bit
more complicated. So if you sell a very compelling,
simplistic story. That, that, that points people away from
the complicated, difficult, maybe slightly painful solution, that actually
you're doing the cause a disservice, that's my opinion
about that.
Yeah, and I think that in the case of
Gary Stevenson, and that's also another way that he
is quite similar to Cristiano Ronaldo, I guess, is
that I mean he presents himself as if he's
the only one doing particular kinds of things out
there like, oh, I'm the only one talking about
economic inequality among The economists, I mean, really, really,
I mean, just the, just the other day you
have Gabriel Zucman on the show. Gabriel, he knows
an econ and he points
to Zukman and like one or two other economists,
but, but in general, yeah, there's a lot more.
I mean, Chris raised the very accurate parallel uh
with um. Uh, OH God, I've forgotten his name.
Russell Brand, cut that out. So Chris pointed out
the accurate parallel with Russell Brand, and, and, but
my little quibble there is he presented Russell Brand
as doing this big turnaround, you know, completely changing
his thing. Actually he didn't, right? Russell Brand has
always been about Russell Brand. Right, the, the actual
stuff that he's doing, the particular topics are less
important than him doing his hypnotic show and dance
and being the center of attention. And I think,
you know, you wanna look at certain figures, you
know, and and we're picking on, on Gary at
the moment, but, but, but apply this to anyone.
Just, just think, are, are they mainly kind of
about themselves? Are they mainly all about you subscribing
to their thing and sharing your thing with other
people, and are they mainly present centering themselves as
the most important locus of attention, and are they
maybe using these issues that you care about? Like
maybe you're a young person, you're looking for guidance
and you listen to Jordan Peterson, or you can't
afford to buy a house, so you're listening to
Gary Stevenson. Maybe it's just possible that they're, they're
playing on your, your normal emotional responses to make
for, for their own benefit. So it's just, yeah,
yeah, you're they're playing on your vulnerability in that
specific case, I mean maybe you're psychologically vulnerable or
you're economically vulnerable or some other issue like that,
right. That's right, and the vulnerability is completely valid
and real. And so it's, it's, it's, it's a
different thing to have an issue with, with the
guru, and, and it's not to say that the,
the, that, the, the sort of things that draw
people to them are invalid. A, a lot of
people, uh, follow our gurus initially, mainly just because
they're curious, and they just like to hear interesting
ideas. And, you know, that's, that's a great motivation.
So, um, yeah, we, um, yeah, we, we, we
just encourage people to consume stuff critically. And maybe
just pay attention to a few of those little
warning signs to avoid getting taken in.
Yeah, great. So let's end on that note, and
I mean, decoding the gurus, where can people find
you on the internet?
All podcast platforms that they care to, and there's
some videos that are put up on YouTube, but
the majority of the content is like in long
form audio, uh, format, so if you're interested, that
any podcast thing is the place to find it.
Yeah, it's like you were listening to Joe Rogan
and you were like, oh, this guy is doing
3 hour BS podcast, so now we're going to
do 3 hour proper podcast.
It takes 6 hours to to to decode 1
hour of bullshit, Ricardo, it's not our fault, this
is how it works.
I think we did a 50 minute episode on
the 9 minute um episode that Sam Harris released,
so you know. We should be careful with throwing
stones.
Yeah, yeah, OK, so look, uh, thank you so
much for coming on the show. It's been a
really fun conversation, and I mean maybe someday we
can do this again. So thank you so much.
Yeah,
you
can
invite Cristiano Ronaldo when he retires. That's.
No, my God, that, that conversation would be hell.
I mean, I would have to confront him with
all the statistics. He gets wrong, and then he
would, he would be coping all the time and
calling me names and uh
no. Sounds fun. I like. Let's hope it can
be red.
All right, thanks very much, Ricardo. Ciao.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegeru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo, and
Hal Herz Agnon, Michel Jonathan Labrarith, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka, Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank
Lucas Stinnik, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro,
Al Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.